alright the new 15 minute game started
um okay let's play let's play see form
okay one for you six most likely yeah we
transpose to a queen's gambit declined
and he went nine f6 I basically am okay
I thought we would get the exchange
variation but he went for Knight takes
d5 so rare move but it's a play a lot of
course and um okay I thought you would
take on c3 and then we would transpose
to yeah the German we say Z me Tosh or
half tarish I proved tarish variation
okay um not be six is somewhat strange
because it just loses time ok i will be
should be three to make it difficult for
him to to play c5 usually black would
take on c3 and then play c5 immediately
to detect the center it's a little bit
of a mix of a grid fault greenfeld and
at the Queens gambit and I would expect
not sure we should be four we should be
seven you know yeah interesting now
should I play just Nadia 30 yeah I guess
just 93
uh-huh I thought I can just take here
and then even even defend the pawn with
before if he retreats okay let's let's
take first and see what terms are what
is plan is this i considered completely
unplayable because of 95 k but damn it
was most bad anyway not be five here not
be five he would be forced to play 9 a-6
I guess and then I've more than one good
good option but let's say not be 5 9 a-6
some okay i could give this check here
it would most likely need to take and i
take with the pony I just have a Monsta
extra pawn on d6 and the other idea I
think I go for this night be 5 9 a-6 and
then maybe before protecting this this
pawn we cannot take on before because of
97 with the fork maybe on before you
could play b6 this is so an idea because
on the way I play c6 then you would have
Bishop takes before check yeah
this is some bit inconvenient but maybe
I can play I like this before IDM would
like to make it work
yeah maybe this is not possible really
before b6 it looks terrible for black
butt
I ok did it it is this this is very good
for white but let's say B 4 B 6 a-3
threatening see 6v takes on c 596 check
takes rook t6 then a six double attacked
and I win c5 back also very good
B from B 6 a-3 b.tech see 596 check
takes rook checks yeah I try that if you
play something else other than v6 black
is basically lost so he needs to you
need to really find b6 okay it's pretty
obvious move but I don't know
and b6 at a 3 plant okay doesn't play v6
Wow ok then just this one on b6 and I
have just c6 yeah black doesn't really
have any convenient moves what should we
play Queen f6 Queen essex 1999 f6 maybe
it'd take it for maybe Nyjah for coming
up
yeah maybe
I could go 96 now it takes on d6 attack
with the pawn and threatened d7 if it
takes before I can play d7 yeah this is
one good option
if I just protect you fall with Bishop
d3 yeah it's also what's a pretty good
clerical play Bishop d7
yeah it's not that easy to decide
everything sir looking fine okay
yeah naughty 47 points the bishop come
on it's not that easy
yeah I didn't really put up much
resistance here
yeah I need to take on this i don't know
otherwise i can even play the aid well
then I'm a piece up and also threaten on
b7 when I just dead on a six it's pretty
much resigned ball hey I should have
played maybe root d8 and try to put up
some resistance why does some clearly
better but that some still needs to be
played out yeah but d8 you cannot even
take with the rook then the Queen
because I've made so I would be I know
what is the screen up yeah
oops yeah I'm a queen up black resides
yeah yeah this was an opening disaster
yeah I think I'm important here was some
bishop be 696 is just just a bed set up
but I guess Bishop e3 is important to
really make it difficult for him to play
c5 as you could see c5 really wasn't
playable and if he cannot play c5 here
he really is very passive he would need
to play castles then maybe 97 tried to
prepare for c5 but white has just nice
and high and just just compare this to
typical lines in the groom forever black
has the bishop on g7 to attack before
it's much more active on g7 than on
yourself and yes c5 and really pressure
on the center and here white has just a
big center and black has nothing yeah
this just just as done terribly
backfired yeah okay let's go for a new
game this one was rather quick